welcome to the David packman show I am
fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in once again today for David
Pac-Man we've got a wonderful show
coming up for you today Jim Jordan is
being sued by Alvin Bragg Melania Trump
is furious at the media for talking
about all of her marriage problems
Dianne Feinstein is facing more and more
calls to resign after it was revealed
that she has missed more than 60 votes
this year and of course
all the legal problems with Donald Trump
all of that and more is coming up on
today's program so let's jump right into
it Alvin Bragg Manhattan district
attorney has announced that he is suing
Republican representative Jim Jordan and
pretty much the house Judiciary
Committee trying to stop a subpoena that
Jordan issued last week
for Mark pomerance
now I had already thought that the idea
to subpoena Mark pomerance by Jim Jordan
was very dumb
if you're not familiar with Mark
pomerance he is one of the two former
assistant prosecutors at the Manhattan
DA's office along with Carrie Dunn they
worked under Cyrus Vance on the Trump
investigation and pomerance and Dunn
resigned last year and pomeranz has
revealed since then in both his
resignation letter and his new book that
he resigned because when Alvin Bragg
took over from cyvance he pretty much
killed the investigation into Donald
Trump
pomerance has gone as far as to say
that he advance
actually had the indictments drafted
against Donald Trump he said they were
less than 10 days away from charging
Donald Trump with financial crimes
and then Brad came in put that
investigation on ice and the rest is
history right
well Jim Jordan for some reason thought
it would be a smart idea
to bring pomerance into the house
Judiciary Committee to testify because
he thought pomeranz's testimony would
somehow prove that Alvin Bragg had
actually weaponized
the Manhattan DA's office to go after
Trump
and he weaponized it to go after Trump
by not going after Trump according to
the guy Jim Jordan
wants to talk to in the house so
um if it's a little confusing don't
worry it's very confusing Jim Jordan's
strategy here makes no sense at all
pomerance is not going to waltz into the
house Judiciary Committee and say oh
yeah Alvin Bragg absolutely weaponized
this no he's gonna say based on what
he's already said that Alvin Bragg
should have gone harder after Donald
Trump and then he's going to start
laying out all the evidence they had
against Donald Trump with the financial
crimes
so if pomerance goes to that Judiciary
Committee hearing it's going to make Jim
Jordan look even dumber than he already
has this year
like that's a good thing I want that to
happen
but I can understand why Alvin Bragg
doesn't and that of course is why Alvin
Bragg is suing to stop this subpoena
from happening and honestly legally
speaking he has very strong grounds
under which to challenge this subpoena
he can easily say that obviously because
these are ongoing investigations they
have not been closed we under New York
state law are forbidden from turning
over evidence from turning over
documents related to ongoing
investigations to third parties and at
this point because Congress does not
directly oversee the Manhattan DA's
office they would be considered a third
party it'd be no different than handing
over the information that they've
gathered to Fox News
that's kind of how Congress is for the
Manhattan DA's office you're just an
independent third party sure you've got
some power
but you have no power here
so he has very strong legal grounds
under which to challenge this subpoena
but I kind of wish he wouldn't
I really really really want Mark
pomerance to waltz into that uh chamber
and spill the beans on all of the
horrible evidence that they uncovered in
their Trump investigation that is what I
want to see and I think a lot of people
probably want to see that as well if
we're gonna air some dirty laundry let's
air it out let's put it all out there on
the line for the world to see because
that's what Jim Jordan wants to do and I
think in this particular instance we
need to honor Jim Jordan's request
we need to give him exactly what he
wants
because I believe it was Oscar Wilde who
said you know there's two great
tragedies in life one is not getting
what you want
the other is getting exactly what you
want
so let's give Jim Jordan exactly what he
wants let's give him Mark pomerance's
testimony about the investigations into
Donald Trump let's let the entire
country hear what Mark pomerance has to
say about all of that evidence about the
indictments that they had drafted
and about why those indictments didn't
get filed let's hear it from him
but that's not what Jim Jordan wants to
hear it's what he would hear but it's
not what he wants to hear he wants to
hear pomerance go in there and whine and
cry and say oh Alvin Bragg made us look
at this stuff and we didn't want to we
knew it was phony baloney
yeah that ain't gonna happen
but
flip side of the coin as I said I
understand why Bragg doesn't want this
to happen
if pomerants were to go into a Judiciary
Committee hearing and start saying that
Bragg was a weak prosecutor we had all
this strong evidence he chose not to do
it it's going to make Bragg look bad and
then you're going to have people on the
left as well as all of the freaks on the
right hating on Alvin Bragg and that's
not what we need right now
I am still annoyed I'm still angry that
Alvin Bragg did not go after Donald
Trump for the big Financial crimes that
pomerance and Don and Vance were all
investigating and ready to indict him
for I think that was a mistake I think
that was a giant misstep based on the
statements that pomerance has already
made publicly it seems very clear that
they had Donald Trump red-handed in a
lot of these instances now that would
have been up for a jury to decide
but now a jury is not even going to get
the opportunity to decide that
and that's not fair
if the indictments were ready as
pomerantz says they were they should
have been filed
Bragg didn't want to go that route
Bragg went the route he did he got his
indictments you know 34 counts against
Donald Trump trial coming up probably in
about a year so it all worked itself out
but Bragg doesn't want palmerance to
talk and again I understand why and I
understand there's laws in New York that
would likely prevent pomerance from
saying the things that I want to hear
him say
but
Bragg has the law on his side Jim Jordan
only has politicization the
weaponization of the weaponization
committee
and maybe he wins maybe he doesn't we'll
see what happens as this lawsuit that
braggis filed plays itself out in the
court system I love my car which is
electric I love my bicycle and I have to
say that the perfect medium in between
is my electric bike by Electric if
you're looking to spend about eight
hundred dollars or so on an e-bike
electric is where you want to go I've
tried e-bikes that cost seven thousand
dollars and electric delivers the same
performance and specs but at a much more
reasonable price point I take my
electric e-bike everywhere these days
I've almost completely ditched my
regular bike for now e-bikes are of
course better for the environment than
taking a car the e-bike gives you more
flexibility and range than a regular
bicycle you can go further you can see
more my e-bike is just my favorite form
of cardio at this point it comes fully
assembled to your door it includes a
bright LCD display seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist and a
powerful battery that's removable so you
can bring it indoors for charging it's
also fully foldable so I can put it in
the back of my car and they have
financing for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below